we are all about powering progress
together by providing clean energy
solutions and you know that doesn't
necessarily mean energy in bulk it
actually also means providing access to
energy who people who don't have it so
what I'm going to announce today is a as
a goal that by 2030 we will provide
access to electricity to a hundred
million people who do not have it today
so we will make our contribution but we
have two billion people still to go that
have not access to modern energy as we
know it now you are investing an awful
lot in clean energy solar power you've
taken shell into electric vehicle
charging in a big way what proportion of
your capex is that taking up well the
whole new energy is business as we call
it which is indeed renewable power but
also biofuels and hydrogen etc we set up
to two billion dollars by 2020 this is a
nascent business for us because an
emerging opportunity and and of course
if you really want to make this one of
the four main threats for shale oil
guess chemicals and renewable power this
will have to step up but you cannot step
it up immediately we have to learn how
to put integrated value chains together
we have to understand how we can make
strong returns in this business and only
then I think we can step on the gas so
to speak and accelerate but this is two
billion dollars of investment in this
space it's not trivial there are not
many companies in the world investing at
that level in renewable energy now
you've taken shell into LNG in a very
big way presumably you anticipate demand
being for stronger in coming years than
in conventional crude oil well
absolutely if you look at the at a
conventional oil and gas part of the
energy mix we're going to need it for
many years to come we believe that power
is going to be or electricity is going
to be the energy of the future in this
century we will see electricity probably
be 60% of the energy mix so three times
as large as what it is today but in the
meantime we will also see for a very
long time oil and even longer gas play a
role now if you look at gas which will
continue to grow much faster than oil we
didn't gas energy is
the fastest growing energy source energy
carrier primary energy carrier we want
to indeed play big in it we want to make
sure that whatever we do and build is
going to be sustainable for the long run
so that means that it has a very
competitive cost of supply but also a
very low carbon intensity so take the
project that we just sanctioned in
Canada
this will be an LNG project with a
carbon intensity that is half the
nearest best project if that's of that
category so we know that we are building
things that are future proof I just
mentioned this project in Canada that's
a twelve billion dollar investment does
this herald return a big oil into mega
projects yeah so what we said this is a
project where the plant will be about a
thousand dollars per ton per an
investment level you can work out how
much it is we have forty percent of the
plant and it's sixteen million dollar
plant it billion dollar plant yeah I
think what it will do is it will help
fill the gap that we see growing and 20s
when supply of LNG will fall short of
the available demand and we will
probably need a few more projects to
help fill that VAX that is growing up
we've seen that coming for a few years
we have been working on a number of
opportunities to mature and take an
investment decision energy Canada is one
of the first ones in that and that's in
that family it's a risk that crude
prices having risen so strongly oil
companies lose that discipline in terms
of how they allocate capital I'm sure
that risk is there but that risk will
not apply to shell we are very very
clear we have set twenty five to thirty
billion dollars is the range within
which we want to invest as of course we
have been through a period of very tough
oil prices they have been interesting
right at the bottom of the range but
I've also been very clear thirty billion
dollars is a hard ceiling and we will
not go up off the ceiling and what about
the future direction of crude prices
over the next six to twelve months
anybody's Cassie in it I think it's
probably fair to say that you know the
fundamentals will support sort of our
price levels that we are seeing today
$80 is not an unreasonable price we have
to build new supply capacity to meet
growing demand but also to offset
shrinking supply all the time so you
know we will need the strong oil prices
that we are seeing today to avoid
another price spike in the future manda
has been significant under investments
but in the near term we all know oil
prices are driven by sentiment events
geopolitical or other events around the
world that will move prices a few
percents a day in a way of course it's
nothing to do with the fundamentals of
supply and demand have you been
surprised by the strength of the
recovering crude prices a little bit I
would say I think first of all I've been
surprised that it took a little bit
longer to come back but I think now that
it is coming back certainly the run-up
that we have seen in the last few weeks
has been very strong again it is more
driven by sentiment than fundamentals of
fundamentals point towards something
like this and of course a rapid rise in
in prices is not good for anybody it it
will indeed as you enter to earlier it
could bring again inflationary pressures
it may also bring inflation in general
but it will also bring potentially
shocks or difficulties through the
economic system
nobody is served by that also not
companies like us we like a stable
environment a stable oil price so that
we can plan our cash flows in a sensible
way and we can also plan you know our
capacity our resources our people in a
sensible way now Saudi Arabia is at the
eye of a storm at the moment over the
disappearance of a journalist in in
Istanbul does that worry that's all that
the Saudis might retaliate by depressing
production well of course we follow this
closely and and not just because of the
point that you mentioned that that just
may lead to further Geel political
tensions and that may affect the markets
but you know developments like this are
of course developments that keep
everybody sort of glued to their phones
and understanding what's going on and
and we are we are among that let's hope
that that these things will clear
themselves up we understand what what
really happened
and that indeed you know nothing happens
to the the security of supply and the
energy system I think again that would
be a very unhelpful outcome for
everybody concerned